hace tres semanas busca a los había sido
recuperada por el ejército ucraniano
muchos vecinos pudieron volver para ver
el estado de sus viviendas hoy el
ejército ruso ataca de nuevo están a
poco más de diez kilómetros en el
batallón kraken integrado por es
militantes de la formación
ultranacionalista azov roslan a una
combatiente nos pide ocultar su rostro
cuenta como la situación es inestable
un día puedes estar tranquilo y después
el ejército ruso trae más soldados y
armas y la situación empeora es difícil
saber lo que va a pasar pero esto es
dirigirse toda esta zona está controlada
por las fuerzas especiales un batallón
que se llama kraken y ahora mismo se
puede escuchar el sonido de la
artillería hace unas semanas la zona
estaba muchísimo más tranquila que lo
que nos estamos encontrando ahora mismo
la granja archiv no es de trincheras los
grupos de asalto aseguran los
territorios retomados y defienden esta
parte del frente junto al ejército
regular el comandante vikingo su nombre
de guerra confiesa que necesitan
armamento para responder al nuevo ataque
ruso
ahora nuestra contraofensiva se ha
paralizado atacar es siempre más duro
que defender es momento de recibir
nuevas armas y entrenamiento
como el patrimonio
no
el número de bajas en ambos bandos es
incierto pero los cuerpos se acumulan
con el paso de los días
alexander teniente general del ejército
es uno de los encargados de recoger los
cadáveres de militares rusos en este
vagón refrigerado amontona las bolsas
que luego serán intercambiadas por
soldados ucranianos fallecidos en la
buscamos cuerpos de soldados rusos que
han invadido en nuestra tierra los
recogemos para cambiarlos por nuestros
compañeros muertos en un futuro así
ellos pueden enterrarlos según sus
tradiciones
cada día a las 11 de la noche vuelven a
sonar las alarmas en esta ciudad a
oscuras y los ataques al caza jarquín
santifica en el noreste de la ciudad
continúa siendo objetivo de la
artillería rusa los pocos vecinos que
quedan viven en situación grave de
emergencia humanitaria